Are you familiar with the drug, D-O-N, for reducing glutamate?
Yes, I am familiar with it, but I haven't written anything on it because I can't prescribe it.
So I know there are some, I know I talked to several doctors who do prescribe and they were excited.
They thought it was going to make some difference with especially people who have glutamate driven cancers.
I get a drug that has side effects too and I would think that the side effects with a drug that's going to reduce glutamates can be emotional side effects too because glutamate is a neurotransmitter.
It's used in a neurotransmitter throughout the body and it's used heavily in the brain as a neurotransmitter.
You need glutamate to wake up in the morning, you need glutamate to function and to think and to concentrate.
Glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter, but it's been shown that people that have a little bit excess glutamate defects on their
gadgets that produce excess amounts of glutamate from glutamine because glutamine is converted to glutamate is they have been shown to be more intelligent people and people that are more driven and get more things done, more successful in life, but there's a fine balance.
Access glutamate leads to OCD issues, a lot of people that are successful have some OCD issues, but access OCD can be a problem. It can be very life damaging.
So I would think that one of the side effects of a drug that's going to reduce glutamate is going to be a loss of drive, a loss of concentration, a loss of mental clarity, things like that.
So with any drug, there's always issues.